Paul telomerase hit the headlines
however I think we have to put it into
perspective it is not the Fountain of
Youth however it is a significant
breakthrough we have to put it into a
much larger perspective first of all we
know that DNA is sort of like a shoelace
it has plastic tips at the end every
time a cell reproduces the tips get
shorter and shorter and shorter until
finally they fray and you know that your
shoelace without the plastic tips will
simply fall apart that's what happens
inside a cell a cell for example your
skin cell will divide about 60 times
that's called the hayflick limit then
the cell goes into senescence and
eventually dies so in some sense every
cell has a biological clock it is doomed
to die after about 60 reproductions
however telomerase can eliminate some of
the the contraction of the chromosomes
and the chromosomes can maintain their
length so at first you may say aha we
can now defeat the biological clock but
not so fast
first of all cancer cells also use
telomerase cancer cells are immortal
cancer cells are immortal and that's
precisely why they kill you why are
cancer cells so dangerous because they
are immortal they grow and they grow and
they grow until they take over huge
chunks of your body meaning that your
bodily functions cannot be performed and
you die so we have to make sure that
when you hit ordinary cells with
telomerase that you don't also trigger
cancer in the process now also you have
to realize that genes are also very
essential for the aging process it turns
out that we know what aging is aging is
the buildup of error that's all aging is
the buildup of genetic and cellular
error as cells begin to age they begin
to get sluggish because genetic mistakes
start to build up now cells however have
a repair mechanism they can repair down
to their cells otherwise we would all
basically rot very soon after birth
however even the repair mechanisms
eventually get gummed up and then the
cell really starts to get old
as a consequence so then the question is
can you accelerate cell repair that is
another branch of gerontology which is
being looked at using genes and using
chemicals to accelerate the repair
mechanisms for example if I take any
organism on the planet Earth from yeast
cells the spiders insects rabbits dogs
and even monkeys now and I reduce their
caloric intake by 30% they live 30%
longer in fact the only organism which
has not yet been deliberately tested by
scientists are Homo sapiens all the
other species obey this basic rule you
starve them to death they live longer
this is independent of telomerase this
is a function of the wear and tear that
we have on the cells and this is the
only known way of actually deliberately
extending the lifespan of any organisms
almost at will now what we want is a
genetic way of mimicking this mechanism
without having to starve yourself
because how many people do you know
would be willing to starve themselves in
order to live 30% longer not too many so
then the question is are their genes
that control this process and the answer
is apparently yes there's something
called the sirtuin genes sir - being the
most prominent of them they in turn
stimulate certain enzymes among them
resveratrol which is found in red wine
for example so this does not mean that
drinking red wine or taking telomerase
is the Fountain of Youth I don't think
that anyone has a Fountain of Youth yet
what I am saying is we are now finding
pieces of the Fountain of Youth
tantalizing clues that mean that perhaps
in the coming decades we might be able
to actually unravel the aging process we
don't have it yet don't go out to the
drugstore and stock up on these kinds of
chemicals and enzymes thinking you're
going to live for
forever however it is conceivable that
in the coming decades will come very
close to finding it